у відповість означає дин незалежності відра
see which до вас парадом мало
балтійська держава на мага йти до
монстр вати силу яку стіл і терезі так і
друку позовних наш чай на полігоні в
адаж
was quite після анексії росією у криму
латвії опусти але відпочивається на біс
співати та крима до курин зради у наш політ
на мої будні та ви часто був і ставив
вони там ще мало чи кримський загинув
вказують нам потребами шармі так
зростати та фінансування з латвії член
євросоюзу то на підлогу за вуста не рік
адже до альянсу трохи ніс більшого свою
про сутність конче
учням з Едгарс ринкевич вказуючи на
значний вниз ок в оборону і саму латвію
закята з помічаємо acer улема вийди про
бюджету та податкова хвіртку
лише одна стаття витре вона пропонує
дискусіям оборонний бюджет
ми на деякому олегу бача дати латвії
якорі в криму у машини витрати на між
кінцевих від нижньої росіян і він і в разл
та виду російської пропаганди
випусти президентом США дональда трампа
ці прогнози руху з путіним посилала
з turbo винесла твіттім виду на wattpad
and sings ми не знаємо чоловік думати та у
путіна шина думати і в Росії
очевидно для нас лише ще прибрала трампа
нас які шини відома
трампа селектор пагорба з видом спарюючись
все буде добре
труб і slade і позитивніший ендже трамп
і бути і настінкою тупим відлито в сочі
вірити потягну членство в нато таяться рахунок
значить теж подіємо ще росіян і на
пошту рушив але над
Тим часом російська пропагандистська
нас тут уже патча вся ось так як
сюжетах російському поза змін відсилають
грому геному балки
двозначні сигнали всю землю до карстової
агресивно схожі на мову україни та молдавії
тут у балтійських країнах включено
вважаємо і політики на користь перед
часників то ностальгії за з рср
ну на і також дунга попрядно нецах
суверенних держав
шаврин стоїть теж за кілька кубометрів і
дриг латвійці регулярно проводять
тренінги за долю американських
десантників
нехай її нагота вниз до оборони на за
води